one of our speakers
has been playing piano since he was
eight and loves to travel anywhere so
let's actually throw out places for him
to travel and see if he's either already
gone there or wants to add it to his
list
and speaking of travel
our other speaker is training for an
expedition to the himalayas that's
coming up in six weeks
so we have some great travel plans
coming up please welcome bernardo and
iggy
thank you
thank you thank you jared
and uh what a fantastic atmosphere you
have here and um
so hello and warm welcome everyone to
who is here live
and if you are watching the recording
hello
to youtube
it is a real privilege for us to join
you at this art conference and we are
really excited and humbled to share with
you our project our project robin which
is an experimental semi-automated
open source r package uh for marketing
mix modeling mmm
uh that was created by us uh at facebook
marketing science but you know we get to
all that so before we start a couple of
quick intros i mean the quick intros for
both of us
i am igor or iggy as you know everybody
calls me i'm a facebook marketing
science partner based in uh london uk
and i'm joined here with bernardo
hi everyone my name is bernardo lares
i'm venezuelan but located in colombia
and i'm really happy and excited to be
sharing this with you today
so we are both from marketing science
team at facebook and you know in general
facebook is a very very mission
mission-driven company and you know to
give people the power to build community
and bring the world closer together
but the mission and the goal of
marketing science inside facebook our
team is we want all businesses to grow
by transforming their marketing
practices that are grounded in data and
science and do it in a privacy same way
and this is where idea of robin that
this open source library came from and
you know and building the community
around it as you will see shortly robin
uses various mathematical and machine
learning techniques to estimate the
marketing channel
effectiveness and efficiency
and it is built for like modern granular
digital data sets so of course you know
mmm or econometrics is not new but what
we are you know it's a long-standing
time-tested method but we are aiming to
bring it to its digital future enable it
for you know many independent variables
make it suitable for modern digital
direct response data rich sources
but also we are really interested in and
what we really want is to build a
community of mmm methodologists uh
people who would be who we could
interact with and discuss innovation and
contribute to the uh open source
robin itself in in fact is a
manifestation or an expression of our
overall facebook vision uh about mmm uh
you know bringing it sort of into the
tangible form so we foresee the
evolution of mmm to become
you know machine learning supported very
very granular being able to give
tactical uh as well as well as strategic
marketing
recommendations being semi-automated
uh still have an analyst oversight
calibrated with experiments or you know
ground truths and we talk about this and
you know deliver insight on faster and
on continuous basis so this is obviously
conditioned on using the best possible
highest quality data
coupled with you know contemporary
methodologies
we as facebook actually conduct a lot of
research into into the mmm as a
technique and in order to move forward
we believe there are three key
developments with you know associated
three three
benefits based on the latest research
that we that we have conducted so first
one is minimizing human bias in uh in um
in the in model building so this can be
achieved by you know using using
something like
using uh ridge regression for example as
well as automated hyper parameter
selection and other
other
sub
sub modules such as profit
aligning with ground truth is obviously
of absolute importance
you know in uh model all models you know
contain
um some kind of error but you know
making sure that we we are able to
validate and calibrate with experiments
or with geo tests uh is of utmost
important and finally you know in order
to bring mlm to its digital future it
has to it has to provide
insights in a much more agile way and
more actionable
uh
so we will talk about continuous
modeling and how that how that is work
and bernardo we will deep dive into it
so really what we are trying to do and
and we move from the classic mmm to what
is currently in project robin so instead
of manual modeling
we're looking at hyper parameter
selection instead of like static models
can we can this be more um
more frequent and more dynamic uh and
how do we deal with you know things like
manual seasonality uh or you know having
only statistical validation so so this
is in a nutshell uh
what we what we have and then now berna
i will hand over to bernardo to take you
through the sort of details and the flow
behind behind robin and how the how the
modules look like in r
thank you iggy
well to better understand the flow
behind robin we can cluster all the code
into four main modules
the first one we have
for feature engineering where we run
some transformations to all media
variables so we can account for the
carryover the diminishing return effects
and the span-rich non-linear
relationships that may exist between
these variables
we also add seasonality and trends
breakdowns features
with the help of the profit our library
and adding all of these new features
often increases model feed and reduces
the outer regressive patterns in our
residuals
this second module the the core model
runs a rich regression with
glm net or glimnet
whichever it is pronounced
with cross-validation
to the to to transform the data results
from the previous model
we can also enable another parameter to
use the ground truth calibration if we
have been able to measure with
experiments now we're going to talk
about why this is important
and the third module is
a combination of steps and options for
model selection and model refresh
once we have several bottles trained
with the help of never
python library imported via reticulite
we calculate a set of optimal solutions
using the multi-objective hyper
parameters optimization evolutionary
algorithms and we output the best pareto
results that should be considered as the
best fits
when
you have additional updated data and
you'd like to refresh this selected
model then you return to this step and
retrain the model
with your new updated information
and this capability enables using mmm
as a continuous reporting tool and
therefore makes it quite more actionable
and the last module is the budget
allocator which brings actionable budget
allocation decisions based on all
previous steps and results
using the selected model results and the
saturation curve of each paid media
variable
with the robin allocator function we
will provide the optimal mix of spend
that maximizes the total response
as i'm sure you'd expect
we can constrain and force any of the
channel spans so the tool adapts as best
as possible to your marketing strategy
so as you can see in this process we are
using several modern methods to help
automate and improve the classical
mmm process
but today i'd like to highlight
only three of those so weibull adds
socking
which enables flexible decay rates over
time with this methodology we can uh
benefit to
to better reflect the uncertainty of
carryover in the consumer behavior of
the product
and
the second facebook never grad
it has a bunch of algorithms to for
hyper parameters optimization which
considers thousands of combinations per
minute and helps us find the optimal
combination of parameters that will
minimize the errors in the in record
timings it's super fast
and
ground truth calibration to improve the
model's fit and performance based on
true value measured through experiments
so
these three contemporary methods are
very much related to what iggy just
mentioned
which are minimizing human bias aligning
with the ground truth and enabling
actionable decision making based
on data and science
so
minimizing human bias is one of the key
challenges robin aims to solve
as you may know already
classic mmm models rely heavily on the
experi on the experience of this of the
analyst that is uh
developing it
especially when selecting the right
explanatory variables to be considered
into the model
assigning the correct ad stock and
saturation curve shapes and parameters
and determining the trend and
seasonality
so what techniques does robin use to
help the final user automate and
unbias these decisions so first using an
automated multi-objective
hyper-parameter optimization with an
evolutionary algorithm allows to
efficiently sample thousands of possible
ad-stock and saturation curves
combinations while minimizing
the three main errors
model error the decomposition distance
and calibration error i'm going to talk
in a few minutes about each of these
the second is we run reach regression
with cross-validation
this is a regularization technique that
deals with intercorrelated explanatory
variables in our data set
and it prevents
us from overfitting and allows more
freedom when choosing the variables to
train our models with
and the third is the profit seasonality
decomposition
which uses a facebook open source
machine learning library for time series
forecasting we use profit to
automatically decompose the trend and
seasonality information and include them
as additional features
here in this chart displayed on the
right
shows the the performance of the
multi-objective optimization run by
never quite over 10 000
iterations using our dummy data set
included in the library
the the axis represent the two objective
functions to be minimized when calibrate
when calibration is not provided because
when we provide calibration we'll have
uh
three objectives
as the number of iterations increases
we can clearly observe a trend to the
lower left corner of the plot
and this is a clear proof of navrograd's
ability to drive the model results
toward the desired direction in an
evolutionary way so and the red lines
shown are the first two third pareto
fronts which contains the best possible
model results from all iterations
so the second contemporary benefit i'd
like to mention is calibration
with a calibration we can improve our
model's predictions using causation data
instead of pure correlations
so we strongly believe that integrating
experimental results into our mmm is the
best choice for model selection
experiments such as randomized
controlled trials are
causal by nature and can be seen as the
ground truth impact
of our treatments
so what we do when providing calibration
data is minimizing the
mean absolute percent error
between our predictions and our ground
truth results
to take advantage of this approach we
add this
additional error into the hyper
parameter optimization algorithm to be
minimized and to ensure closer results
to the experiments we apply stronger
weight to this error
we can use this technique to calibrate
any channel and time period within our
mm's date range so the more experiments
the better
then the third challenge and benefit
that robin addresses is enabling
actionable decision making information
which can be achieved with the
diminishing return curves the add stock
curves and the budget allocator
for for the budget allocator we use a
non-linear solver that allows equal and
unequal budget constraints to help us
define optimal budget allocation for the
upcoming cycles
and the diminishing returns and as the
curves the model prints for us will help
understand the inflection points and
locate these sweet spots for our
investments on
every channel
so now let's check out some of the
outputs robin models
returns as well
so one of the main outputs will be
this
this is an example of a one sheeter with
several charts
in order from left to right and top to
bottom as you'd read
at any text we will have first the the
waterfall chart with the total
decomposition of all the independent
variables and their dimensions
then the predicted versus actual to
visualize visualize the time series fit
compared with the model prediction and
performance metrics so you can see how
how uh
how fit is the model
and then we have media decomposition
chart
showing the media share of spend versus
the share of effect of roast or cpa
and this plot also gives us a hint on
the intuition of the objective function
that minimizes the decomposition
distance to avoid extreme cases
the fourth is saturation curves they
show the heal functions with induced
saturation curves for each media
variable
and then we have the average media decay
rate comparison when using geometric
stock it will show you the theta hyper
parameters selected
and when using weibull given that it has
a two parameters with changing decay
rate over time
it is a bit more difficult to illustrate
intuitively so in this case we use a
visual approximate to the weibull
average decay
and the last plot is
fitted versus residuals to visualize the
model diagnosis
given the residuals and trends
so uh um
as as you might know we are super
excited about this project and we would
like to invite you to join the community
and start being a part of it either as
an active user or as a collaborator
this is an open source our project we've
started where marketers from different
backgrounds and sources gather up to set
a scalable trustworthy methodology
to optimize marketing spends across
different channels and understand their
rois based on data and science
so now it's your turn to test it and
start being a part of it you may visit
robin's website on github i'll ask iggy
or someone to copy and paste it and
share it in the chat
in there you'll find detailed
step-by-step guides to try rubbing out
dummy data sets so you can test it if
you don't have the data yet
we'll have details about robin's
features and advantages
and a couple of public success stories
of actual advertisers who have been
using robin to take allocation decisions
as of today you can also install robin
as an independent package
running the code shown in the satellite
into your local machines and we're very
much looking forward to keep growing and
improving its functionalities with you
and we'll submit the library to cran
as soon as it had a
a stable
validated version
so as a final statement
i'd like to highlight that our goal here
is to create a community of
methodologists to debate and impose mmm
innovation in an open source environment
so back to you iggy
thank you and
just to maybe bring it a little bit more
to life with the two case studies that
we've been humbled and lucky to have
advertisers confirm so one is
resident
which is a israeli e-commerce
company
selling furniture and mattresses online
uh
and the other one is the central retail
group
uh in thailand
but we have many more uh other users but
you know like you can you can find links
to this uh online and and see what
they've done and how they have actually
gone and used robin in
in their
uh in their situations
um
so what's next i mean actually this
conference came
really
really in advance of our next uh release
which is robin 3.0 we are releasing on
the 29th of september at the robin
community summit i will
show the link to it shortly for those
who is interested in joining it will
have a few
[Music]
new features and new innovations
uh the model refresh and the rolling
windows will be slightly touched upon
already
this will be officially released end of
the month
it will also have
support for organic variables
those are such that obviously drive
marketing impact but do not have
necessarily associated
spend or dollars this could be
you know organic content for example
and we've made some tweaks and
improvements to the optimization
convergence of the never algorithms
as well
and finally of course we will be
releasing this as a package and as
bernardo just mentioned hopefully in
crown zoo
we are also working on
our shiny app to
enable
and bring robin to a broader community
of non-coder on non-coders so this is
currently in closed beta but we're
hoping probably towards the end of the
year uh we might have a
a broader update for for this so we're
really excited about this one obviously
code is great but you know bringing it
in and ui is going to be uh it's going
to be great and i know we are the at the
our conference we're just going to
mention we're also working on the python
translation so there will be a python
version uh hopefully soon as well
and then we
really
gonna start working on robin 4.0
uh which probably gonna have a
major feature dealing with regional
models and mixed mixed models
um
so
probably a nest or a nested model so so
there are plenty of exciting uh feature
features to do uh two things that we
already mentioned uh one is the
uh robin sami driving community summit
uh on the end of the month so those of
you who are interested to learn more or
here actually we're gonna have the
uh we're gonna have the analysts from
central group as well as uh from
um next resident come join us and
discuss uh we're gonna we're gonna
showcase some of this uh in much more
detail
uh if you have any questions for us i
know there is no q a but please join our
community group on facebook
facebook.comgroup.org uh we are all uh
admin there it's quite lively out there
so you can you know pop your question
there or interact with us in any shape
or form there so you know please do join
us
uh at the summit and and join us join
our community group and you know you can
you can keep an eye on this project and
it feels interesting
uh to you too
so
we
would like to thank you very much i
think we are on time um
for your time and attention today
and uh we can't be we can't wait to
have you part of our robin community and
um happy analyzing
thank you all
bye
thank you very much for bringing us our
last talk of the day i saw there's some
more chatter about glimnet and in the
chat while you two are speaking uh
people came across we should make a
package called glam net